[Music]
well clearly he's disappointed
you couldn't hold that in michael oh
gosh after this moment all i could think
was
please choose your next words wisely
i don't know what to say and obviously
he didn't either
for the first time since her weight loss
and breast reduction surgery
angela revealed her transformed body to
michael
and his reaction let's just say it was
honest i haven't got this far on my
journey for my husband to tell me he
doesn't like what he sees
we'll get into what michael said once he
got it together and how
angela felt about it all plus you sound
like a
psycho jovi straight up told yara that
she is not fun
since she became a mom you need to stop
being a crazy mom
and thinking that you can't leave your
baby we'll chat about her recent
behavior that has jovi
questioning everything hey 90 day fans
fam
it's melisia i'll be honest this
is starting to feel like the angela and
michael recap show
i've been covering them consistently for
the last few weeks because
quite frankly compared to everyone else
right now they give me the most to talk
about
natalie tends to have selfish uh ways
with mike and natalie it's just like
break up already andre and libby's
storyline is starting to feel a bit
staged
unbelievable i'm telling you like
unbelievable and tiffany
girl get your babies and just leave
already
head back to the us your decisions with
money lately have been
weird considering the fact that season
six is almost over
hopefully we'll get an interesting twist
with those couples soon
this is our date night but in the
meantime if you're wondering how
angela ended up naked in the bathtub on
facetime with michael after last week
you tell me you [ __ ] because you give
us zombies
here's how that happened it's been over
two weeks since me and michael broke up
and i'm still really upset with him but
deep in my heart
i really want to mend things with him at
the top of the show
in an attempt to mend things angela put
together a video chat
that included michael and her longtime
psychic hi michael
hey tricia psychic tracy hey
tracy so michael i'd like to
um do your cards for you is that okay
okay it's fine michael michael don't
believe in your gift
he's getting ready to see do you not
believe in my gift he will after this
i am i am going to ask the angels
what's going on in michael and angela's
relationship can you tell me
when to stop stop
that's angela when i see this card
it's saying to me about um he needs to
be there for you
but i feel that he he he focused on
to me it's a lot of material things
oh he cares about okay
i'm gonna let you keep listening go
ahead michael
angelo is your wife and you need to be
there for her
no matter what of course i forgive her
now i forgive her
forgive me for what yeah
well what for some reason i just got
this card i needed to pull this card
yeah i see angela and she sees you
but she also says i don't know if this
is family i don't know if it's friends
around you michael
but this card is saying to me that you
know
she needs to defend her position because
something is not right here
if you don't sort it out you'll lose her
is it just me or does it sound like
psychic tracy
didn't get her information from the
spirit world
but from angela now i'm not discrediting
her gift
but the reading came off very one-sided
she needs to give me all speech
i mean for me to express myself oh my
god more
space then you shouldn't have got
married [ __ ]
what where is the angel card that says
you shouldn't call your husband a [ __ ]
[ __ ] i need the space you do nothing
but he's sleeping
you need more space your maya was a part
you can't get any more space than that
is she not supposed to be the mediator
he don't get what i'm saying
michael went on to explain that he meant
he needs more space to express himself
i mean she needs to like listen to me
sometimes not happening after this
conversation
it didn't seem like much was
accomplished ask the cause the question
is michael scaming me angela walked away
questioning if michael is scamming her
what is your gut feeling italian
i don't know what to believe i don't
want to believe it because i love him
and he walked away feeling misunderstood
what i really need from angela is for to
listen to me and to respect me after the
reading michael revealed that he wanted
to continue to put his foot down
but after psychic tracy said he could
lose angela forever
he got scared after psychic tracy
said i could lose her forever i'm really
scared to do that right now
that's when he called his wife to
explain why he started to act different
after her surgeries
the surgery thing i don't i didn't
like it but still went ahead and do it
so it really
taught me the fact that my opinion
didn't count michael then apologized for
not being there for her when she needed
him the most
no i'll be there for you okay
i'm sorry surprisingly they had a
sensible conversation
where they both were able to express
themselves without things getting
disrespectful
but i think it's important to note that
that was only the case because someone
aka michael chose to put his pride aside
for the sake of peace
i love you so much okay i love you i
still love you but after a few i love
yous
they made up and that's when angela felt
like it was time to show her man
a few things
[Music]
this is our date night you want to dip
in my pool
[Laughter]
oh my goodness i'm not gonna lie it was
nice to hear these two
laugh and enjoy each other it's been a
minute
angela was blowing bubbles to michael
it's more teasing
than pleasing and he was catching them i
just want to blow his
bubble
they both were into it when i picked up
the call and i saw my wife
in the tub and covered with the bubbles
i failed to
know i was i was
i was happy he reminds me of why
i married her yeah with me
a part of me feels like i have no
business saying all after what they've
been through sign of the [ __ ]
shot up a bit shut up but hey
at some point you have to say it's not
my life
it's yours if these are the choices you
want to make fine
i genuinely hope it works out well for
you
i really want to see how your body and
your push looks like now
since when you had the surgery i haven't
seen anything
this is when angela got nervous as we
all know
michael likes big boobs and we can't
forget this moment right after her
surgery
[Music]
so i get it i would be nervous too
let's go ahead and take a look at his
reaction and side note
whoever is filming angela with this
camera
knows her a little too well now
oh my gosh
[Music]
why
i don't know what to say
it's still okay for me for me
it's okay don't worry
michael has learned from the past
and although his reaction wasn't ideal
it put a huge smile on angela's face
my heart was just racing he didn't
sugarcoat nothing
he didn't jump in and say oh and and
boom me and say oh the views are
beautiful
i mean am i disappointed you don't love
my new boobs of course
but he gave me his approval and that's
the michael that i need
well in that moment michael made sure to
be gentle with angela's feelings
which was appropriate but here he is
detailing more of how he
really felt finally seeing angela's
new boobs to be honest i felt down no
disappointed because they are not big
anymore and um our nipple looks
a little bit strange to me because i
know that's where she was
operated on but i still loved my wife
and uh there's nothing i could do about
it
eventually i hope i will learn to love
the new books too
yeah i hope you do michael for the first
time i think all
season these two ended an episode on a
good note
michael gave angela a little strip tea
oh my goodness
showed us some things we would have
rather not seen
pump your penis and angela painted a
mental picture
that was a little too clear for me can
you imagine what the sex is going to be
like now
now i can really wave that american flag
on top
wow using an american flag in the
bedroom
that's kinky but i guess if you're
trying to get to america that red white
and blue would turn you on
wave that american flag on top
all right let's get into jovi and yara
don't get me wrong you're being a good
mom but at the same time like you're not
fun anymore
before jovi had that honest moment with
his wife
yara hosted ukrainian christmas which is
celebrated on january 6th
at their new place she thought this was
great because jovi wasn't around for
american christmas because he was away
for work
i won milos and jovi's first ukrainian
christmas to be
perfect things seem to be going well at
first jovi invited his mom and cousins
over to enjoy the festivities
hey but it all took a turn when everyone
at the table
started to question yara's parenting
choices because she allows baby myla to
sleep in the bed with her and jovi
now i'm not a mom yet but i do know to
be told that you're doing something
wrong when it comes to your child
it's never a good feeling it will be a
lot harder later as she gets older
because it's going to become her routine
how do you change that right
she'll miss me she'll wake up and then
she's here with my mama
i want to actually when she will grow up
do you have a house on my back here
sorry
you sound like a psycho ooh look at
y'all's face
psycho she did not like that word
she's not gonna be very independent if
she
stays in your bed i know she'll be
lashing mama's nipple for the rest of
her life
reliant on you for absolutely everything
good luck jovi
yeah yeah joey it's gonna be rough for
you bud
okay yeah myla having a house in yard's
backyard
is a bit extreme psycho but beyond that
i personally know the feeling that comes
with getting ganged up on
about a subject you're really sensitive
about so
what yara did next didn't surprise me
although
it was rude it took so long come on you
need to tell your family they need to go
home because milo needs to go to sleep
after jovi's family drove two hours for
this ukrainian christmas
yara basically kicked them out they
weren't even done eating but
they also didn't like the food so oh the
fish is so nasty
there you go thank you you're welcome so
what you want to tell you guys
i'm sorry i don't want to be mean and
rude but milo needs to go to the bed
all right you telling us to leave
we need to leave for real it's six
o'clock and she sleeps in y'all bed she
could go lay down with her right i'm
sorry
why do we have to leave i just told her
that it's the first time i've seen my
family in a long time
i don't even want to tell you about that
yara didn't budge
and eventually their guests got up and
exited the house
according to her that's what people do
in ukraine they eat
and they leave it's not the cajun party
is ukrainian christmas
the next day jovi was extremely upset
about this
so while they were shopping for a crib
he told her that he misses
the old yara what did you miss about all
me
you were fun don't get me wrong you're
being a good mom but at the same time
like you're not fun anymore
jovi also proposed that they go on a
trip without the baby
but yara wasn't feeling that you have
new year for the rest of your life joe
you wonder you don't want
i want this life but at the same time
you need to stop being a crazy mom
and thinking that you can't leave your
baby but since joey beans home he argued
with me
about every parenting choices and now
he says i'm not fun person not fun mama
i've been raised in newborn by my own
and i think it's not fair that he's
judging me
joey need to accept that he is his new
life
because i will not let him to push me
around i hope yara finds some balance
eventually
she is really attached to the baby which
is a great thing because
she's her mom but yara can't forget that
she's
also a wife jovi's wife at that
hopefully with time things will get
better alright
well next week angela's trust issues
with michael are back
front and center peter suggested
maybe i should go to the fertility
clinic to get my phone tested
you know what you got to do when you go
get your sperm you're going to have to
masturbate
so you know what michael you can go to
that clinic if you want and you can sit
there
and masturbate but she'll do it with me
on the phone what is he gonna do
she don't hurt the magazine that's a lot
that's a lot angela
all right 90 day fans film to stay
updated on all the latest news coming
out the 90 day universe
make sure you stick with et because we
are covering it all
i will see you next time
you